[Musik]
weil die partie gut sehr gut die partie
bei super international oder mag kommt
aus frankreich sascha aus russland und
selber aus syrien selber ist die beauty
ja sie ist ein flüchtling finde ich das
selber in deutschland bleiben keine
ahnung sie hat doch keine
aufenthaltserlaubnis sie spricht sehr
gut deutsch
stimmt sie macht einen deutschkurs und
lernen sehr schnell und welche sprache
sprichst du nico englisch war ja ein
bisschen und spanisch und ein bisschen
deutsch
ich spreche spanisch ein bisschen
englisch und ein bisschen deutsch
welche sprache sprichst du ich spreche
deutsch englisch und italienisch aber
sehr schlecht
woher kommst du welche sprache sprichst
du ich komme aus thailand
ich spreche teil chinesisch englisch
deutsch französisch und italienisch
wow hat man schnell her
das foto von der tante jahre
es gibt eine antwort und einer adresse
[Musik]